face away from me
do not Flex
don't Multiplex
is there a shotgun somewhere because
there's a shotgun shell right here on
the seat
it's got more gear than I do yeah
he's got better gear than we do yeah
yeah oh really dude do not move
D all right get out
I kind of I don't even want to figure
out though
stay there
all right with your hands up stand up
out of the car
slowly hands up
face away from me
do not Flex
multiplexing
what yeah
see the base for a kid's car seat
you got a pack down here
I'm gonna block lava some shotgun shell
what's up
hmm
Colorado
unless it's going to be Barry boy Edward
Robert Robert Young versus going to be
Jonathan John ocean Nora Adams
date of birth is going to be 12 16 of
1997. okay
now
yeah
all right let's go ahead and touch my
car right now okay go ahead sir
[Applause]
we got a warrant
yeah yeah
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
flew out into the inside Lane almost and
then over cracked it almost hit another
car so I
was good he's going I don't even know
how fast so
I come over that Hill
see he disappeared as I went past his
anchor I see him shut off the lights in
here and uh and I come up here and he's
like no I'm not giving you my name and
obviously he's dressed like that it's
like I'm gonna be honest it's a stolen
vehicle I don't know when I saw it I
don't know where I'm at or where I'm
going
would you mind heading over to the
owner's address and see if they know the
birds or if he's got their car yeah yeah
right down there on Madison
oh
nine millimeter Beretta
so
I want to move this somewhere else or do
you want to go and find out the or go
talk to people that own that car
good job Kristen win the traffic stop of
the night
I'm sure
is there a shotgun somewhere because
there's a shotgun shell right here on
the seat I'm not seeing one because I
saw that too
looks like we've got a gun case back
here
more shells hey there what's that plate
right there
the front plate
where's that firearm at I gave both of
them one to Jason
okay
man this guy was loaded for
it's got more gear than I do yeah he's
got better gear than we do yeah
I wonder who supplies him
should ask
he even has a full face mask yeah
I was wondering if he wasn't gonna maybe
go commit a robbery that's what I'm
wondering too I'm wondering if this is
like burglary stuff or something
so
it looks like the launch paper
yep
good job
oh my gosh
oh
that is scary
that explains it
I'm an additional serial number on the
shotgun when you're ready
it's gonna be a Dickinson I believe it's
one to five David five seven zero one
let me double check that
and I don't see any other numbers on it
and where did you know it
I didn't turn my camera on sorry folks
I got mine
I'm such an idiot it's all right stuff
happens
okay
that's kind of understandable
what do you want to get him going jerk I
don't care who Kristen you can do it or
if you want to stick around
I I thought I smelled alcohol on him
oh
I wasn't talking to make sure that
there's alcohol Crystal yeah the only
just like merchandise I'm gonna ask him
I would just have to say hey while the
other officers thought they could smell
alcohol
I need you to blow into all my hand he
does have some dipping because he spit
but
hey John
how much have you had to drink today we
could smell alcohol on you yeah quite a
bit okay I do
what's that
you're too quiet for me I can't
understand you I said
okay yeah
well
so
um all right what would you be willing
to do volunteer roadside sobriety
Maneuvers sure okay we'll probably do is
go to the police department and do those
rather than right here and then um get
those done okay
all right give me just a second
okay so he said he'll do roadside
maneuvers I said maybe we could go to
the police department and do those would
that works
yeah okay
thank you
I didn't manipulate it I'll look for any
other serial numbers
it's kind of weird that that one would
just be like that you know
um
illegal
yeah we're gonna have to take all of
this
yeah
there's a shooter Monday night
foreign
burglary tools that's what it looks like
to me
grinder screwdriver
all of those little pigs yeah